when amazon announced its new kindle
paperwhite this month i was tempted to
buy it on the spot
and add to cart
then right before i hit the buy button i
heard that little voice in my head
joanna you know it isn't 2007 anymore
right you don't really need a 120
e-reader especially when you have an
ipad
actually you're wrong little voice in my
head there's two reasons i keep buying
e-readers and why i've been waiting for
this new paperwhite
the first reason is this new
high-resolution e-ing screen which i can
actually use to read on in direct
sunlight unlike the ipad's mirror i mean
screen
the six-inch e-ink screen isn't only
readable in direct sunlight it now has
the same high resolution 300 ppi screen
as amazon's more expensive 200 kindle
voyage from afar the difference between
the old paper white screen and the new
one isn't always obvious but up close
you can no longer make out the pixels
the lettering looks closer to a real
paper book than anything else out there
that said e-ink really does feel like a
decade-old technology even though page
turns and response times have gotten
faster there's still a slight delay when
you turn pages and tap on menu buttons
it can be frustrating the second reason
i prefer to read a long novel on an
e-reader the great distraction-free
reading experience
when i read a good novel i don't want to
be distracted by notifications and other
apps i just want to sink my teeth into
the words and this kindle does that
better than ever there's a new amazon
created font and text formatting has
been improved i also love seeing how
long i have left in a chapter and the
built-in light is great for reading in
light and dark environments but while
the paperweight is light comfortable and
has weeks of battery life it's still
pretty thick if you want thinner you
have to spend 80 dollars more on the
voyage and even then it feels like it
should be thinner if you're wondering
about the e-reader competition amazon
barely has any these days barnes noble
still sells the nook glow light but it
hasn't been updated in about two years i
am a fan of the waterproof kobo aura h2o
but it's 180 and doesn't have the
kindle's high res screen nor its popular
ebook store
i'm sure one day the paper white will be
slimmer and have an even better screen
of course that's how amazon keeps
getting me to buy these things
whatever what else you gonna buy today a
vcr